in der Aussprache zum Europäischen Rat
heute und morgen hat jetzt Amira
Mohammed Ali Fraktionschefin der
Linksfraktion das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie und ihre
Regierungsmitglieder nennen sich ja
selbst gern die
fortschrittskoalition leider ist das
einzige was in unserem Land ernsthaft
voranschreitet die Spaltung der
Gesellschaft Millionen Menschen wissen
nicht mehr wie sie ihr ganz normales
Leben bezahlen wollen unsere Wirtschaft
droht eine schwere Rezession in ihrer
Regierung aber herrscht das Chaos und
wenn es darum geht die Bevölkerung
wirksam zu entlasten dann wird endlos
gezögert und gezaudert und was dann
rauskommt ist meistens morgens Chaos und
Murks bei den späteren
entlastungspäckchen Chaos am Umgang mit
Christian Lindners heiliger Crew der
Schuldenbremse und auch die
atomkraftdebatte hat wieder gezeigt dass
es ihnen vor allem darum geht den
jeweiligen Befindlichkeiten ihrer
Minister gerecht zu werden und eben
nicht um die Belange der Bevölkerung
aber das geht so nicht
man stelle sich einmal vor Sie hätten
all die Stunden die sich sinnlos
gestritten haben dafür genutzt die
Menschen vor der Preisexplosion wirksam
zu schützen indem sie zum Beispiel den
versprochenen strompreisdeckel
eingeführt hätten oder einen
vernünftigen gaspreisdeckel und zwar
jetzt und ich am Ende der Heizperiode im
März was ist das denn
und auch heute haben sie sich wieder
gelobt für ihre lächerlichen
entlastungspäckchen und ich möchte ihn
dazu eines sagen ich meine sie als
Norddeutscher sollten doch wissen es
reicht nicht den Deich auf zwei Meter
aufzuschütten bei 10 Meter Hochwasser da
braucht es mehr und die Katastrophe zu
verhindern das ist die Wahrheit wir
brauchen sofort ein energiepreisdeckel
Verbrauch ohne Verbraucher genauso für
die kleinen mittelständischen
Unternehmen und zwar auch bezahlbaren
Niveau außerdem müssen alle Haushalte
mit kleinem mittleren Einkommen wirksam
entlastet werden wir wollen 1500 Euro
wintergeld pro Haushalt plus 600 Euro
für jedes weitere Haushaltsmitglied das
würde wirklich etwas bringen und wenn
sie sagen dass dafür kein Geld da sein
dann ist das einfach Quatsch besteuern
sie endlich die perversen übergewinne
der Energiekonzerne die liegen jetzt
schon bei über 100 Milliarden Euro
außerdem führen sie endlich eine
gerechte Vermögensteuer ein ich meine
wenn Sie trotz dieser existenziellen
Krise immer noch nicht bereit sind die
Superreichen gerecht zu besteuern dann
regieren sie einfach an den Belangen der
Mehrheit vorbei so ist das leider und
außerdem muss selbstverständlich die
Schuldenbremse auch im nächsten Jahr
ausgesetzt werden alles andere ist
unverantwortlich Vernunft wo die
Ideologie das muss auch in der
Finanzpolitik endlich gelten
der Präsident
der Chemieindustrie der warnt davor
Deutschland könne vom Industrieland zum
Industriemuseum werden in der
Stahlbranche rot aktuell tausenden
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern der
Arbeitsplatzverlust denn wenn sich die
Lage nicht bald deutlich verbessert dann
wird die Produktion nach und nach in
Länder mit geringeren Energiekosten
verlagert werden das darf nicht
passieren Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch ihre außenpolitische Bilanz die es
leider ernüchternd ja seit fast acht
Monaten tobt bereits Putins
schrecklicher Krieg in der Ukraine und
es muss doch eigentlich endlich auch bei
Ihnen die Erkenntnis gereift sein dass
dieser Krieg nicht weiter eskalieren
darf nein er muss möglichst schnell
beendet werden und das geht nur über
Verhandlungen ja es braucht jetzt
Diplomatie statt Waffenlieferungen und
es geht eben nicht das möchte ich meinen
aller Möglichkeit sagen das denjenigen
die das aussprechen was vernünftig ist
das Bienen unterstellt wird dass sie
Verständnis hätten für Putin das ist
einfach Blödsinn und es macht das
Geschäft genau von denen die diese
Argumente instrumentalisieren für ihre
Hetze das ist die Wahrheit das ist
instrumentell sie sind doch sonst immer
für Aufrüstung unsere Militarisierung
nein unsere Haltung ist der konsequent
nur Diplomatie und Vernunft sind der
richtige Weg und das gleiche das gleiche
gilt übrigens auch für berechtigte
Kritik an den allgemeinen
Wirtschaftssanktionen fakt ist diese
Sanktionen die Schaden Deutschland der
EU und den Ländern des globalen Südens
enorm Russlands Kriegsmaschinerie rollt
aber unbeeindruckt weiter die russische
Wirtschaft ist weiterhin stabil herr
Scholz sie haben selbst versprochen es
würde keine Sanktionen geben die uns
mehr Schaden als Russland handeln sie
endlich danach
und bevor sie uns jetzt weiter oder
wiederkommen mit ihrer angeblichen
wertebasierten Außenpolitik sie
unterhalten beste Beziehung zu
Diktaturen wie zum Beispiel nach Saudi
Arabien dahin liefern sie jetzt sogar
Kampfjets Kampfjets mit denen die sauge
Luftmasse Waffe systematisch Zivilisten
im Jemen bombardiert in diesem
schrecklichen Krieg sind bereits 400.000
Zivilisten ermordet worden und das
Sterben geht weiter und ihre
Außenministerin an einer der bärbock die
sagt dazu allen Ernstes man müsste ja
nun mal die Bündnisverpflichtungen
erfüllen und ohne diese Lieferung der
Kampfjet und Saudi-Arabien kümmerte
Deutschland in sozialen Bereich ja noch
mehr sparen Kampfjets für die
Kindergrundsicherung so stand es
treffend im Spiegel ich meine wie
zynisch ist das denn und wie zynisch ist
das eigentlich den Kindern im Jemen
gegenüber nein Menschenrechte die müssen
immer und überall gelten und eben nicht
nur da und dann wenn es in
geopolitischen in den Kram passt danke
mit dem Ende der Rede von Amira mit
Mohammed Ali Karton verlässt der
Bundeskanzler jetzt den Sitzungssaal
denn er muss ja dann auch gleich los
nach Brüssel und hat aber hier die erste
Rede Runde abgewartet bis eben zur
fraktionshilfe der linksfra